hey everyone welcome back so today we're
going to cover a very practical subject
which is how to choose a classical
guitar
if you're at all like me when I went to
buy my first classical
I had no idea what I was looking for you
know I saw a room of guitars some are
shinier some were different colors and
some were very expensive but I really
didn't know what made them different so
this video is in two parts today part
one is going to be all about equipping
you with what I think is sort of the
need to know before you show up to the
guitar store to make a purchase now in
part two we're going to talk about what
to do when you actually have an
instrument in your hands that you might
be considering buying how can you
actually tell if this instrument is good
quality or not by the way this video was
made in collaboration with a really cool
guitar shop in Germany called Seekers
guitars and part two is actually already
out and it's available on their channel
so if you go to the link in the
description you can watch that right now
but for now here is part one of choosing
a classical guitar
foreign
now to start let's just make sure we
understand how to pick out a classical
guitar from you know dozens of other
types of guitars we might find at a
guitar shop
a classical guitar is an acoustic guitar
with nylon strings and nylon strings are
usually kind of a see-through plastic
key looking string material you'll find
the top three strings our nylon and the
bottom three are wound with metal if you
see guitar that's all steel strings
that's not a classical guitar
other features include a headstock which
is this part here with pegs on the back
side so not the front or sticking out
the sides but they're in the back you
can also tell it's a classical guitar
because there are 12 Frets and at the
12th fret the body starts
and then there are 19 frets
total usually lastly you can tell
because at the bridge which is this
wooden piece here the strings are tight
around not held together with the PIN
all right so now that you know how to
recognize a classical guitar when you
see one let's talk about price range it
turns out that you can buy a classical
guitar for as little as 80 on the
internet I'm sure or as much as a
quarter of a million dollars right I
have another video where I played a 275
thousand dollar Torres guitar which is
actually this is a replica of a Torres
guitar but I played a real one from 1888
and because of its historical value it's
priced very high so that's a huge
Spectrum how do we know how much to
spend
um well of course first is you know know
how much you're able to spend
um know what you can afford but I would
advise you not to buy the cheapest
guitar if if that's an option for you
um from my experience guitars under a
hundred dollars I wouldn't waste my time
they will simply hold you back in the
learning process you might quit because
you think you're no good at the
instrument but in reality the instrument
isn't very playable so I would go over
the 200 Mark mainly because generally
that's sort of the the price range where
you get into solid top instruments this
this top face of the instrument here is
called the soundboard
and that is arguably the most important
part of the instrument in terms of the
sound it produces it's like a vibrating
membrane that resonates and gives us so
much of our the character of our
instruments and when you buy instruments
that are too cheap typically the top is
made of a synthetic laminate wood that
just doesn't sound so great and what we
want is a solid top one solid piece of
of wood which you tend to get when you
get over that price once you get over
that hump you get a lot of factory made
instruments which are varying quality
and at a certain point you enter into
the realm of more professional level
guitars which tend to be handmade not
factory made and that could be you know
somewhere around the two thousand dollar
range and up these These are made by
luthier somebody one person who makes
the guitar from beginning to end and
those tend to be the finest most
professional level level instruments but
of course there's a huge Spectrum there
and you can you need to buy what you can
afford but at the same time generally
the more you spend the more playable of
an instrument you get in the better
bigger of a sound you get as well
next you should know that guitars
actually come in a variety of sizes so
this is about a full-size guitar but if
you are buying a guitar for a
nine-year-old This Tall this is too big
they make half size guitars they make
three-quarter size guitars so you should
get one that's appropriate for the size
of the person and also you know if
you're an adult who's simply on the
shorter side or you have small hands
they make 7 8 size guitars so it's very
important to get something that's
comfortable for you not to force
yourself to hold an instrument which is
uncomfortable a term you might hear if
you go into a guitar shop is the scale
length of a guitar and that means the
length from the saddle which is this
white piece here all the way to the nut
which is the white piece here and the
average scale length in centimeters
would be 65 centimeters but actually
this guitar is 64. so here we have a
slightly smaller guitar some guitars you
see are 66 centimeters so there's a
variety and I don't think one's better
or worse necessarily as long as it's
right for you
now earlier I mentioned the importance
of the sound board and that it should be
a solid piece of wood usually Spruce or
Cedar and so here we have the two main
types of guitars the yellowish brighter
color is Spruce and it has a brighter
sound so easy to remember because the
brighter color is the brighter sound
it's usually a harder wood and then the
darker color makes a darker sound it's
not because of the color but it's
because the nature of the wood but so
the cedar is the darker color it's a
softer wood which makes it more mellow
darker sound and here's the cool thing
there's no objective answer here I mean
this isn't better than this or vice
versa we're into the realm now of of
taste you get to decide you know which
you like but you should definitely play
a cedar top and a spruce Top guitar at
some point and find out what you prefer
now both these guitars are made by the
same maker Sears guitars and so actually
if I just strum a chord on both let's
see if we can hear a difference
so starting with the spruce
[Music]
and now the the cedar guitar
I don't know how much of that is coming
across on the microphone but in person
the difference is night and day this is
such a more mellow dark dark chocolatey
sound you know and it feels different
like I can feel the resonation of the
instrument against my chest so they're
very different instruments but I
wouldn't say one is better the clarity
of the spruce is beautiful and the
chocolatey richness of the cedar is also
beautiful in different ways all right
another thing you need to know about
classical guitars is that the wood on
the sides and the back of the instrument
called the back of the sides it can be
many different types of woods here we
have flame maple
and here we have Indian Rosewood
right
however I have to admit that in my
experience the back and the sides is
sort of a low priority wood of the
instrument it doesn't seem to make as
big of an impact as other components of
the instrument especially not the sound
board that seems to be the most
important piece the back and the sides
sometimes you get also mahogany or even
exotic Woods like Brazilian rosewood or
KOA but you know like I said I I think
it doesn't make a huge impact in fact
Torres the famous maker who codified the
shape of these instruments in the first
place this is actually a Torres replica
here by Serge guitars
Torres even did an experiment once where
he made a fantastic guitar but he used
paper mache for the back and the sides
just to I think prove a point you know
and so maybe it has a bigger impact than
I that I am aware of but for me I would
at least say it's lower priority than
the rest of the instrument
another important point to consider is
whether to buy a new or used instrument
unlike cars you know guitars don't
really depreciate in value in fact they
can even appreciate in value if the
maker gets famous or if there are none
of those guitars left sometimes with
older instruments you can get you know
scratches and dings on the instrument
but those are very superficial I would
say that those don't really matter what
matters is if if the instrument was
taken care of if there are not you know
cracks that were too many cracks that
were repaired in the instruments or
serious problems like the strings are
too high the action's too high as long
as the instrument was taken care of
there's nothing wrong with an old guitar
in fact sometimes it's wonderful because
that important soundboard can actually
improve in sound over time as it's
played it can open up and learn to
vibrate in new ways and like fine wine
improve in character with age so it's
kind of a cool thing
um new guitars however the appeal there
is for example if you go to a luthier
you can get a custom instrument exactly
with the woods you want and the scale
length you want and and everything
specified to your to your liking okay I
have just one more point I want to make
before you head to the guitar shop
be cautious to not fall into the Trap of
mistaking shiny and decorated guitars
for Quality guitars
I remember when I was 16 or 17 and I was
going in to buy my first more expensive
classical guitar and I went to a guitar
shop and I saw up high there was this
super shiny guitar covered in mother of
pearl inlays and decorations and things
and we took it down and I could
literally see my face in the finish of
this guitar I had so much finish on it
and I made the classic mistake of
assuming that the decoration meant that
this was actually a really good guitar
turns out that this guitar was not so
great the sound was really dead but I
really was taken by the beauty of the
instrument so be careful don't make the
same mistake I did in short I would say
that in fact we want less shiny guitars
because we want to let the instrument
resonate that is your sound resonation
and as ever saying before about the
importance of the sound board being like
a membrane if there's too much lacquer
if there's too much finish on an
instrument it suffocates the wood
there's a little experiment you can do
to prove how important it is that the
sound board vibrates
if I push on the top of the instruments
I can really deaden the sound so
all right
see how it mutes the sound that's
because the instrument needs to vibrate
and I'm suffocating
it by pushing on it and that's
essentially what too much finish does so
if you see another guitar where you can
see your face in it it's too much like a
mirror actually I would say that's not a
good thing
um the less finish the better in fact
and French polish tends to be the best
way to finish
a guitar
so I really hope you found these tips
useful and now you feel very equipped to
head to the music store and ask all the
right questions please do check out part
two Below in the description because
when you get to the shop and you now
have to play an instrument it's useful
to know a series of tricks to figure out
whether or not a guitar is good quality
or not
okay guys thanks so much for watching
please do subscribe and if you're
interested at all in learning the guitar
the loot or other plucked instruments uh
please do check out my online music
school called arpajato you'll find it in
the description below at arpajato.com
and we specialize in all things that go
pluck so if that's of interest to you
and you'd like to do some online lessons
please do check it out
okay take care
[Music]
foreign
[Music]